they lie about everything next tweet
this is ilhan Omar noted racist
Socialist Communist awful human being
the Earth just broke the record for the
hottest day in a hundred twenty thousand
years in fact we broke in fact we broke
in on three separate days National
Climate emergency now and of course this
was fact checked by Twitter the
community notes thing which is just
spectacular the source for this claim
appears to be the University of Maine
climate reanalyzer which has added a
recent notice making it clear that it
should not be taken as an official as
official observation records because the
real records on this stuff really only
go back to like the late 1800s if we're
to believe any of this stuff the idea
that ilhan Omar has any sense of what
was going on temperature wise on Earth
120 000 years ago he's completely
absolutely completely insane but can you
put the Tweet up one more time because
what really forget all the lies I get it
you guys get it like they lie about
absolutely everything and it's all just
done as a farce to Keep Your Eye Off the
Ball as I said earlier the last line is
the is the key part of this she just
says a whole bunch of nonsense but why
does she say it to get us to a National
Climate emergency now and you know
what'll happen guys we will have
National Climate emergency lockdowns and
eventually they'll tell you you can only
be outside for a certain amount of time
and you'll only be able to eat these
things because they're gonna have to
close an awful lot of farms because
those cows you guys like eating meat you
like that rib eye but those cows are
farting and those cow farts are doing
something to the environment but do not
worry they will be eating well
[Music]
thank you